Fun with your new best buddy hey that's
your fault your dad likes me you dated
idiots your whole life oh he was right
about one thing
I married to a stud yeah I felt so bad
about selling you out I thought I would
maybe make it up to you mm-hmm wait wait
I can't I mean I want to but I'm not
supposed to for the next three days oh
that's right I forgot
mm-hmm all right well guess I'll just
read a little and then I don't know go
to sleep
really that's what you're sleeping in oh
you want me take it off? No!! oh all right
well then pipe down and let me read my
comic book honey I know what you're
doing is please stop oh listen to this
Bamm Pow take that Batman
Amy there's something out here just wrap
it under a cop and I'll be there in a
minute
I'll try but it's Leonard
what what is he doing here I told you if
we left pizza on the counter it would attract
something oh hey guys
sorry I used my keys I needed a place to
crash is everything okay yeah I had to get out of the apartment my wife kept
running out of sex with me been there
why are you trying to avoid having sex
well we just did it three weeks..I was talking to Leonard I have to
go to the clinic for Zach and Marissa on
Monday and I'm supposed to save myself
until then sounds like maybe Penny's not
totally on board with that plan she said
she was but she also said I looked dope
honestly I don't even think I looked fly
so you're willing to go through with
this even though she clearly has
reservations if she has a problem she
should say something she tried to
seduce you if that's not a cry for help
I don't know what is penny doesn't want
to have kids I respect that but this is
my chance to leave a part of me behind
okay but this isn't gonna make you a dad
it's gonna be their baby not yours
although someday if that kid wants to
know why he's short nearsighted an
asthmatic he may hunt you down